there's a really horrible story that
we've known a little bit about for a
while but now more details have been
released and people have been emailing
me asking me to talk about it and I sort
of hesitated because there's really no
no good way to talk about this but I
think there are some important concepts
within it so I'll tell you about it and
then we'll discuss the stories about
Lane Davis Lane Davis is a former Milo
yu-na police intern Milo you know police
is this sort of all right darling who
had to go off the radar for a while
after video became publicized of him
where he seemed to be defending sex with
minors and Layne Davis not only as a
former Milo intern and whether that's
relevant or not we'll decide that's part
of the narrative that's been been told
he also was a regular poster on the
controversial subreddit the underscore
Donald on reddit it's an online meeting
place for trumpets that's the center
also of a lot of controversy and Layne
Davis was all about supporting gun
ownership he was about criticizing
diversity he would spread a Hillary
Clinton conspiracy theories on the
Internet that's sort of his thing and a
few months ago in July he killed his own
dad on July 14th Lane's mother called
991 one call that he wasn't threatening
to kill them but quote pedophiles who
were taking over the country he was
chasing his parents around and his mom
said we're trying to of the 911 operator
said to the mom try to get away from him
and the mom said on the phone we're
trying to but he's chasing us around the
house he's mad about something on the
internet about leftist pedophiles
and he thinks we're leftist and he's
calling us pedophiles and I don't know
what all at one point on the 911 a 911
recording you hear leave the knife alone
said bylanes father later Catherine
calls 911 the audio recording is sort of
difficult to hear but you can hear his
mom running and the portable phone she's
using breaks up and then you hear
screaming and you kind of hear he
stabbed him before the connection is
lost I mean just this
stuff of nightmares right horrible
situation and it turned out that Lane
stabbed his own dad in the chest with a
chef's knife walked outside the house
drop the knife and waited for cops to
show up which they did Layne Davis said
to detectives that the fight had started
over quote whether toddlers could
consent to sex or not and that his
father had called him a Nazi and a
racist shortly before the deadly
stabbing now let's talk about the Milo
yu-na police part first through a
spokesperson Milo responded to an
interview request from The Daily Beast
with a statement saying merely Lane
Davis was a volunteer for me for a brief
period of time prior to my founding Milo
Inc I was unhappy with his work and
discontinued the relationship I then
experienced his anger firsthand as he
threatened me and later went to BuzzFeed
making false and inaccurate accusations
that's the Milo part a lot of the online
contributions of Layne Davis from after
killing his dad or rather from before
killing his dad have since been scrubbed
from the internet website moderators and
editors on different websites have
removed evidence of Layne Davis having
participated on those platforms so
people have said to me is Milo to blame
is the Donald subreddit to blame what is
to blame and I'm not going to give a
different answer for Layne Davis then I
do for this shooter or that perpetrator
or someone if they have left-wing
leanings or someone if they have
right-wing leanings the relevant concept
here is stochastic terrorism okay or
stochastic violence or stochastic
criminality what stochastic what does
that mean
stochastic is a term that's usually
applied to financial markets and the
stock market and stochastic means
randomly determined having a random
probability distribution or pattern that
may be analyzed statistically but may
not be predicted precisely so how does
this apply to terrorism or acts of
violence or blame well here's the
concept if you expose a large enough
audience to the idea that immigrants are
dangerous or that dr. George Tiller
is a baby killer or whatever idea right
the odds become greater and greater that
someone in the audience is going to be
influenced by that message to commit
real-world violence by what they've
heard you say now the classic example is
Glenn Beck Glenn Beck for a while used
to rant about the tides foundation and
that influenced the guy named Byron
Williams to open fire on the i-5 80
highway in Oakland California on his way
to attack members of the tides
foundation now we couldn't have possibly
predicted from watching Glenn Beck talk
about the tides foundation that Byron
Williams was going to go and try to
shoot people at the tides foundation we
couldn't even have predicted when anyone
would have tried to do something to the
tides foundation we can't even really
tie Glenn Beck to any legal blame right
but statistically when you have an
audience and a message like that it
becomes more and more likely that
someone's going to take action so what
about Layne Davis what about this
circumstance well it's pretty clear that
Layne Davis is a mentally ill person
right even most people exposed to the
Donald subreddit and to Milo you Napoles
most people are not going to stab their
father's dead
so there's no question that this is a
mentally ill individual however could
the radical messages espoused by either
Milo or the Donald subreddit or whatever
conspiracy websites Layne Davis was
frequenting could that maybe have
triggered Layne Davis to actually take
action after his parents said a
particular thing I don't know I don't
know the answer this is more sad than
anything this is not a defense of the
Donald or of Milo you Napoles but it's
also not a blaming of Milo and it seems
Milo but if we believe the statement
Milo barely knew this guy or the Donald
so stochastic terrorism is the term that
applies and the important concept is
being aware of the fact that when you
have large numbers of people being
subjected to this type of radical
messaging that particularly with the
amount of access to firearms in this
case it was a knife as well as mental
illness untreated mental illness
stigmatized mental
in this country statistically speaking
these things are going to happen and
many of these media sources could be the
trigger if not the cause